well last year Trump campaign advisor
George papadopolis pleaded guilty to
making false statements to the FBI
unless he repudiates that deal and goes
to trial Papadopoulos will soon be
sentenced to up to a half a year in jail
Simone emocionante Papadopoulos is his
wife and she says she would like her
husband to scrap his plea deal she joins
us tonight mrs. papadapolis thank you
for coming on so you think your
husband's got a better shot in court
during a trial is that absolutely
absolutely there are many evidences
already in the public domain that shows
that his situation smells more
entrapment to set up so than any attempt
to collusion I would like to make a
point which is clear all the crossfire
hurricane operation started based on
allegation of Clinton Elias Alexander
donor who reported to have a
conversation of her drinks in London
with George who were allegedly referring
about the famous dirt on Hillary Clinton
that Mifsud gossip aired about at the
time of their meet in your room now we
know that this person was affiliated to
the Clintons
George has no recollection whoever said
anything alike to alexander donor Mifsud
stated clearly to the italian journal
era pública that is a clinton allies
actually said many times a member of the
Clinton Foundation and today in the it's
speculated that the Mifsud is a Russian
spy who tried to collude with from
campaign specifically with George now
President Trump is saying that his
campaign has been the target of foreign
intelligence obama-clinton allies or
spice to infiltrate the campaign my
husband seemed to be the secretary sure
John and Roger hunt we've got 30 seconds
to 20 seconds is your husband going to
withdraw the plea deal yes or no do you
that's my that's my suggestion I can't
answer right now for him but as I said
that I don't want him to be I want him
to be the sacrificial lamb of the will
chant and there are many exculpatory
evidence 'as many shady people fitting
in the sir I'm sure
to cut you off we're out of time I wish
we had more time thanks for joining us